So we're going to look at different types of pricing schemes. Hey everyone! We are going to be taking a look at natural monopoly and public policy. Now recall one of our barriers to entry dealt with natural monopoly. That was economies of scale, so let's first take a look at it and to do so we are going to be looking at a firm's long-run marginal cost and long-run average costs. So I have a demand curve in front of me and a marginal revenue curve as well. Let's add in our long-run average cost.
And our long run marginal cost. Notice that these are falling the entire range of output so that lets me know that this firm is experiencing economies of scale.
If will allow the firm to produce at the monopoly output then it is going to equate its marginal revenue and long-run marginal cost and it will take that quantity, go up to its demand curve to figure out the price that it charges. Now this is the standard monopoly model that we've already seen.
So we can get our economic profit simply by finding out where the average cost price is going to be
subtracting that from the price that we charge from the good and then multiply that by the quantity that we sell. And this is the economic profit for the monopoly. This is the typical monopoly outcome. However what we are going to find is that the government or governments will allow this type of firm to exist. We've already seen that in our barriers to entry and they're going to say "You know we we like the idea of that you can provide a lower-cost to people and provide more output than two or more firms can, so we're going to look at different types of pricing schemes." And the first type is going to be what we call average cost pricing. This is where you are going to set the price equal to the average cost of producing that amount of units that we have, in this case Qac. That represents the amount of output that we produced where our demand curve intersects our long-run average cost curve. Now, in this case, what we are going to get is a normal profit. That's because total revenue just equals total cost. Pac times Qac is our total revenue and it also happens to be our total cost, in this particular cas. So the monopoly earns a normal rate of return. There's no incentive for the monopoly to deviate from its outcome here.
Now let's have a look at another type of pricing scheme called marginal cost pricing. Marginal cost pricing would be the competitive firms' outcome. They price it where marginal revenue equals marginal cost and you get and that occurs where the marginal cost curve intersects that demand curve. But for the monopoly what we see is that this firm will earn an economic loss because it's average cost is above the price being charged, so what we have to do
is subsidized this monopoly. So we take our quantity, Qmc, go up to our long-run average cost curve and then move over in that amount is the amount, that yellow rectangle that you see there, that is the total amount of subsidies that the government provides to that particular firm. Amtrak is kind of a good example of this. They are a government-owned train, excuse me, government owned business but they run privately, and the government subsidizes Amtrak in this case.
So you know we look at these three types of pricing outcomes and we have to ask ourselves which ones do we like the best? And typically what we see is average cost pricing is the one that prevails. It allows the firm to earn a normal rate of return and it still provides a lot of benefits to the consumers over the monopoly outcome.
Now, that is our natural monopoly. Let's have a look at what we do with public policy when these monopolies exist . The first thing that we're going to do is look at what we call antitrust laws. Now antitrust laws came about in the 1890s--1890 to be exact with the Sherman Antitrust Act--because of all of the mergers and acquisitions that were taking place in the 1870s and 1880s. And there was a lot of what was deemed as unfair
business practices. And so our Congress, back during that time, they decided they were going to pass a law that prohibited firms from engaging in antitrust activity.
One of the key provisions in this act comes from section 1, which says every contract combination in the form of trust or otherwise where conspiracy in restraint of trade or commerce among the several States or with foreign Nations is hereby declared to be illegal. So the government, at that time, was really seeking to stop monopolization, stop anti-competitive behavior. The Sherman Antitrust Act was then strengthened by the Clayton Act in 1914. This one gave the government power to authorize private lawsuits. It also added in a bunch of other little items that we're not going to talk about in this course that made it more and more difficult for firms to engage in anti-competitive behavior. Our second type of public policy is regulations. This is what we have already seen. We have already seen how the government can regulate a Mmonopoly--a natural monopoly--by having them either price at their marginal cost or price at their average cost.
A third type is public ownership. This is when the government steps in and works the entire industry itself or works the entire firm itself. So you may see, maybe not in the United States, but you will see it in other countries state-owned control of a type of business like an electric plant or or water plant or telephone services. Now, again this is pretty common in areas like the like European countries like in some South American countries not so, in the United States, and well I do take that back we do have one in that is going to be the United States Postal Service. Remember they are or have a government granted right to do first class mail and no others can do that, so that is one thing that you may see. Now, economists are more along the lines of allowing private ownership of the means of production because they found it to be more efficient, and if you do look at cases like United States Postal Service you...you see that they lose a lot of money each year and taxpayers are responsible for picking up that tab.
Our last one is to do nothing.
Sometimes it's best just to do nothing and allow the market to work itself because you might find that the inefficiencies created by a government solution is actually going to be more costly than what would have been had we just let the market exist as it is. So sometimes politics do step into the realm of economics and cause more in inefficiencies than they do efficiencies. Uh, so market failure, sometimes as we have, as we view it as a bad thing sometimes it might just be okay. And that's all we have for our public policy and natural monopoly. Hope you have enjoyed it and we'll catch you...well that's it! That's all we have for our series for chapter 15. So we'll catch you the next chapter.